This notion of maximum
variance should strike
a little bit of recognition in your mind
about then notion of fitting a line.
You remember we did line fitting?
Okay.
In fact we came up with
this equation of saying
we're going to measure the error that's
essentially just the perpendicular error
of the points to this line.
And the, and the equation of
the line that we had there was
a x plus b y minus d equals 0.
Or it could be plus d, doesn't matter.
The idea is that a and b was
the normal with respect to the line and
in fact that's what
that says right there.
And if I take the dot product of x and
y on that,
it's supposed to be a distance d away
and that's what this equation says.
Alright, so that was when we were
trying to do a least squares fit.
So then we, we did this quick operation.
We took the derivative with respect to
the d, came up with this formula for
d in terms of the average x,
the average y.
We plug that in,
substitute d equals a x bar b y bar.
We get this new error function E.
Just having substituted.
And we wrote it, this way.
Okay?
And this is where b is this matrix here.
And you can see it's just the x's and
y's in a row with the means subtracted.
Okay?
So what we want to do is we
want to minimize that quantity,
the magnitude of B times n,
where n's going to be the normal AB
that we're going to solve for, and
we said last time that what we want to
do is we want to minimize Bn squared,
but remember, since the normal has to be
unit normal we say subject to n equal 1.
Now, what might be not so obvious
because we didn't mention exactly last
time is that this distance,
these square distances, this
is going to be the axis of least, let's
call this the axis of least inertia.
Right?
[INAUDIBLE] From your physics.
If I've got an axis, then the inertia of
the whole thing is proportional of all
the points, the square distance from
those, of those points to the axis.
So the line fitting here in 2D
is an axis of least inertia.
And like I said,
this should sound familiar to you.
And we, remember we did this.
We, we looked at several
ways of doing this.
We had those in fact back when we
did calibration, we said well.
We have this A, M, because we're
doing M matrix for the calibration.
We said make,
let the norm of that, well,
we want to make it as small as
possible subject to M equal to one.
And remember we were doing this thing
with eigenvalues and eigenvectors, so
it shouldn't surprise you that we're
going to be revisiting eigenvalues and
eigenvectors.